um
[Music]
foreign
strategies for managing anxiety and
feeling happier thanks to all of our
participants who are joining us for more
than 80 countries around the world this
webinar is brought to you by Harvard
online
before we get started we'll run through
a few housekeeping items all
participants will stay muted and the
chat function will be turned off for the
duration of the events
we'll be answering questions
intermittently throughout the webinar
while we will do our best to answer as
many as possible we will not be able to
answer all questions we encourage you to
share your questions in the Q a function
at the bottom of your screen
there you can submit your questions and
view questions from other participants
you can also upvote questions that
resonate with you we are excited to
introduce you to our moderator and
panelists for this event
Anna bartusca Dr Luana and Michael
without further Ado let's begin our
discussion Hannah the virtual floor is
yours
thank you welcome everyone and we are
delighted to have you with us today my
name is Anna vartuska and I'm a Clinical
Psychology PhD student at the University
of Oregon it is an honor and a pleasure
to introduce to you today two
extraordinary experts that will be
guiding our conversation
first is Michael Pewitt Michael Pewitt
is the Walter C Klein professor of
Chinese history in anthropology at
Harvard University his interests are
focused on the interrelations between
history anthropology religion and
philosophy with the hope of bringing the
study of China into larger historical
and comparative Frameworks he is the
author of The Path a new way to think
about everything the ambivalence of
creation debates concerning Innovation
and artifice in early China and to
become God cosmology sacrifice and
self-definition in early China in
addition he is the course faculty for
Harvard online's course the path to
happiness
we also have with us today Dr Luana Dr
Luana is an associate professor at
Harvard Medical School founder and
director of community Psychiatry program
for research and implementation and
dissemination of evidence-based
treatments at Massachusetts General
Hospital
and former president of the anxiety and
depression Association of America
Dr Luana is frequently cited as one of
the leading experts in cognitive
behavioral therapies she's been featured
in Publications such as York Times CNN
and Harvard Business review
she's also been a regular guest on
television broadcasts such as Good
Morning America and podcasts including
10 happier
Dr Luana is the author of bold move a
three-step plan to transform anxiety
into Power which has been lauded for its
clear and practical approach to dealing
with anxiety and will be released
officially next Tuesday Dr Luana is the
course faculty for Harvard's online
course building personal resilience
managing anxiety and mental health
Michael and Luana we are so excited to
have you both here with us today to talk
about Mental Health and Living a good
life
to begin I would love to hear from each
of you how you became interested in this
topic Michael do you want to kick us off
I'll be happy to thank you it's such an
honor to be here with the two of you and
with the larger group
um I got interested in this topic
um just because I was doing two things
um I was reading a lot of Chinese
philosophy and I was living my life and
like for many of us um living my life
was was not always easy and meanwhile I
was reading a body of philosophy that
gave extremely practical advice for what
one could do on literally a daily basis
in one's most sort of mundane aspects of
living and so my excitement really
started there I decided these texts were
probably on to something and these
practices really would be revealing and
that began my path it is lit here
I appreciate your openness to share your
own journey and we hope to hear a little
bit more about that today too Dr Luana
what brought you to become interested in
this topic
well thank you Anna for moderating it's
so nice to be here with you as well
Michael
um you know I for me
um it's been at the transition really
from Brazil to the US not until very
recently I realized that I grew up as a
very anxious kid and you know it's
really tough growing up there was a lot
of adversity a lot of trauma in my home
and you know my mom really did the best
she could to get us um out of our humble
beginnings in into the US and I realized
that about age 15 that I was well my
grandmother let's be honest not I I 15 I
had no Insight in this my grandmother
really caught me avoiding a lot of
things and it pushed me to do what's now
known as exposure therapy and at that
point she really changed the trajectory
of my life and I remember coming to the
US first trying to become a medical
doctor get an MD and I was in Brazil
talking to my grandmother talking about
how much I love the brain how much I
love science how much I wanted to sort
of help people and she's like why don't
you take a psychology class and so I did
I took psychology class and it just made
sense in my brain it's almost like the
things that she had taught me now made
sense scientifically and I never looked
back I the rest became history
thank you for sharing it seems like
mental health has been a topic for many
many years from you know ancient Chinese
philosophy also you know throughout the
duration of both of your lives
um and yeah we're seeing such a rise in
terms of mental health being talked
about in news and on social media and
other platforms can you shed some light
as to why we're seeing that uptick of
mental health being such a Hot Topic
today Dr Luana you want to start
sure I'd love to
um I you know I don't know if it's just
a rise in mental health I think there's
a couple things happening since the
pandemic most of us have had a moment
that it was just too much and so there
was no other way but to talk about brain
health and anxiety and sadness and
loneliness so there is a increase on on
the shared experience of things that
fall under mental health you know the
CDC is showing 30 to 40 percent of
people suffering in clinical levels of
anxiety and depression after the
pandemic and so first I think there's
increase in Awareness second increase of
share Humanity
um and then I think our lives just you
know change dramatically and people are
still not sure how to transition fully I
we expected that our lives could go back
to sort of a new normal so to speak but
I think in many ways we have
transitioning into readjust and that
Readjustment hasn't happened as much
Yeah you mentioned this word anxiety and
we hear it a lot in your professional
opinion what is anxiety
um so let me share an example winning
his idea so this morning I was getting
ready
um for this panel and I looked at
Michael's course
um and I was trying to learn more about
Michael and I didn't know a lot about
York Mike so I looked up and and we have
this new course coming up and so I
looked at our course we had like 8 000
people um registering I was like oh this
is really awesome and I looked at
Michael's course and he had like a
hundred thousand people right sure let's
just be clear here and my brain went oh
my God I'm totally messing up my force
is not going to be success so I'm such a
failure like and and so the first thing
that happens you know we're talking
about anxiety is something happens and
our brain pretty quickly distorts
information at my brain at that point
have no capacity to look how long
Michael's course was open none of that I
just had this narrative on my brain of
like I'm not good enough which started
to make my heart pound and I was like
finish getting ready and I could sense
just this vibration of anxiety and I was
like what am I doing to myself and in
fact later on I was talking to Nicole
and I was like so how long has Michael
scores is being open she's like a year I
was like okay so maybe I'm not that bad
but that is sort of anxiety for you like
our brains tend to misinterpret data
when we are anxious and jump to
conclusions and catastrophize which is
just what I did this morning so Michael
I was not trying to compare with you but
my brain certainly wanted to
um I know I almost dare to say that
maybe happiness is a little bit more of
a comfortable feeling than anxiety when
we think about it
um Michael I want to toss it over to you
and to just hear your thoughts of why
mental health has become such a Hot
Topic and any thoughts you have about
anxiety or the other side of the coin
that we're all seeking happiness as well
absolutely and in full agreement with
the wanna hear I think that is exactly
right
um we've gone through this period first
of all of course the pandemic which was
devastating for so many of us for all of
the obvious reasons
um we have now been in a world of social
media for 15 years that's having a
tremendous impact
um we're facing obviously a very
difficult structural future
um climate change Rising inequality lack
of social Mobility so a growing sense
that the future for us and the next
Generations could be increasingly
difficult so all of those are playing
into the current rise of anxiety
um and of course a sad part of this is
that that although specific things I
just mentioned are new
um much of this is not people have been
wrestling with difficulties of anxiety
for well thousands of years which is why
I'm looking at texts among other things
that that are addressing issues that are
incredibly comparable to those that
we're currently wrestling with so I
think sadly going back to luana's point
it's telling about the way that our
human brain and our emotions operate
um we don't respond well to situations
we invent very complex readings of
issues that are really uncalled for we
fall into patterns of responses that are
oftentimes a very debilitating and this
is part of Being Human now that's the
negative way of putting it let me
immediately say of course the flip side
of that is we are capable of breaking
out of all that I just mentioned in
terms of our ways of responding to the
world which is why if these are
typically human bad ways of responding
we're capable of responding very
effectively which is exactly of course
what what Luanda is showing in her work
and you just wanted your course is going
to be incredibly successful as per
yearbook
ah thank you Mike I love that though I
love that um if I mentioned I love this
piece of like it is just the Human
Condition and our brains is sort of
wired to protect and protect and often
uses out data mechanisms really to make
predictions like my brain this morning
you know it is based on growing up I'm
poor and having this belief I'm not
enough and now I'm an adult I know I'm
enough and yet the brain wants to
malfunction so I love what you said
Michael which is we don't have to
believe that narrative right there is
ways to rewrite our brain um and that's
why um I love what you're talking about
as well
yeah it's really interesting to hear you
both talk about this this idea of
pattern and responding my question to
both of you is if this is just part of
The Human Experience then when do we
just kind of continue on accepting that
as part of the human experience and when
do we really
start to change or what do we do when
does this become problematic and how do
we know when that happens
either of you whoever wants to respond
first
jump in
go for it Michael sure
um I would say it is always problematic
um part of what's sad about the human
condition is we often don't see it so we
see it when it hits a crisis point when
our patterns just continue to a point
where it becomes devastating to those
around us in ways that we're forced to
finally realize
um we're devastating to aspects of our
life in ways that we're again forced to
realize but sadly we are capable of
living our daily life with these
patterns and just kind of continuing day
by day in fact
doing horrible things to ourselves and
those around us without even seeing it
and that can continue for an entire life
now again that's the bad news um the
flip side of that is we are absolutely
capable of breaking out of this we are
fully capable of doing so all of this in
various moments of our lives have
successfully done so and so part of the
goal is to develop practices in which
that becomes part of our regular way of
being instead of constantly falling back
into these patterns that are again so
devastating and yet so normalized in our
way of living that we tend not to even
notice them we just think that's what
life is or what we personally just are
we're just unhappy creatures
I love this mic I love this idea that
like we have to sometimes hit this wall
and this crisis to see it and it doesn't
have to be that way I think that's such
an important message for everybody
listening to us today that you don't
have to get to that breaking points that
in fact you can catch this earlier and
you know the signals are there I think
when I talk a lot about anxiety and I
think about anxiety as a high fever
right it's calling your attention it's
trying to tell you something but in
design itself is not the problem it's
what we do when we are anxious that's
the problem right so for me the example
I shared earlier today I shared not only
to sort of share the vulnerability of my
example but like I went and looked for
data to talk to Michael's point I was
like wait a minute like can I interpret
this this way or is there another way to
do this but I could have done the
opposite I could have continued to avoid
which by the way then would make me
super anxious to be here with you right
and so I love this point of like number
one we all can identify it and that we
can catch it earlier and change it in a
daily basis I mean use CBT on myself
every day and and that's the only way I
think should have a happy life
there's so much good happening right now
I want to slow down the conversation a
little bit Luana to what you just
mentioned about this idea of anxiety
being the fever can you tell us a little
bit more about this term that you use
across your work psychological avoidance
and how it fits into that analogy
so you know for the live streams of my
career everyone that had come to work
with me being in a big organization or
an individual they want me to get rid of
anxiety just get rid of my anxiety but
you know anxiety really is not
necessarily the problem in fact we are
biologically wired to have a fear of
response so I cannot magically get
somebody's anxiety completely gone in
fact it's like losing your pain
receptors if you touch a hot stove and
you don't have pain receptors it's a
really big problem and so some love of
anxiety is expected right the problem is
what I call psychological avoidance
which is anything that we do to try to
make ourselves feel better momentarily
but it has a long-term negative
consequence Let me Give an example if
you're afraid of public speaking you
might just pass on the promotion because
you're so anxious that you just can't
take that promotion if you want to go on
a date but you're scared of other people
you might not go on that date and so
every time we avoid we're physically
actually training our brain that we
can't handle something and that is the
real infection right there are many
moments in my personal life that I'm
terrified I was just speaking at Formula
One and before I went on stage my my
heart felt like just gonna jump out of
my chest but I approached instead of
avoiding so that's why and I often say
it's not anxiety it's what we do and if
we what we do is avoid we're robbing
ourselves of a good life
that's incredibly insightful I'm curious
Michael how that kind of relates to some
of the work that you've done in some of
Chinese philosophy and where it might
diverge or similar
any thoughts full agreement that is
beautifully insightful and yes so a lot
of these texts I deal with with from
early China will say exactly the same
thing so the way they will put it is to
say we will fall into patterns of
responding to the world that we come
just to accept as who we are so Lawanda
going back to your examples I'll just
think oh I'm just inherently bad at at
not that speaking publicly is just not
me and we'll even defend it with
terminology like
um oh that's just me and I should learn
to love and embrace myself for who I am
you know loving my strengths but also
loving my weaknesses and among light
weaknesses or that just I I can't speak
publicly and that's just me and so I
should just find areas of life where I
can just be me and therefore not have to
speak publicly and as you said what
we're doing there is just normalizing
that or taking these patterns we've
fallen into and thinking that that those
patterns themselves actually are just us
that's just who I am and I agree with
you fully rather what we should be doing
is a daily practice where we're breaking
out of our patterns and sticking with
your example if I feel I cannot speak
publicly that's not because of who I am
that's because I've fallen into a
pattern of just being incredibly fearful
of speaking publicly for you'll
perfectly understandable reasons but the
way to do that is to train oneself to
speak publicly and like you I would
generalize this all of these things we
just think we can't do because of who we
are realize these are probably just
patterns we've fallen into and all
patterns are changeable and approvable
and the key is it's a daily process of
just working through your patterns
breaking your patterns and having a much
better way of living in the world so I
think the way you put it is abs
absolutely beautiful
I love this part Michael on this idea
that we even rationalize our patterns I
just think such a good you know we
create a narrative I call this like on
my work I call this a pretzel effect
that like represso information just to
fit a pattern that it doesn't really if
you say it out loud it doesn't make any
sense in fact if if we're talking to if
we talk to our friends the way we talk
to ourselves we'd have no friends right
because like we are so mean just to hold
on to something that makes no sense I
love that piece
yeah I think that I completely agree
um we're going to open it up for some
audience questions here soon and we
received some questions in advance and I
have one that I think really fits into
this conversation a bit so we've been
talking a lot um about this idea of our
patterns get us stuck they're part of
what makes us human they aren't who we
are but our patterns particularly when
we avoid things is some of what's
leading to lack of happiness or mental
health
um a participant from Kenya has asked
how can I differentiate between mental
health and normal life stress
Luana you want to start this one
sure I love that we have a participant
for Kenya so I don't know who you are
but that is awesome I'm so excited that
you're thinking about this and so how do
we separate day-to-day stress versus
like getting to mental health and I
imagine that behind this question this
is the idea of like you know am I just
stressed and it's normal I can handle it
versus like when do I also need to seek
some help and think about what it looks
like and the way I think about this and
and actually Michael said there's a
little bit already which is you know is
this starting to affect your day-to-day
life is it taking too much energy to do
things so often usually when we're
talking about mental health in the
spectrum of like diagnosis we're talking
about somebody that is having trouble
sleeping they're having trouble
concentrating they are having trouble
engaging with the meaningful things and
so the the way I put this very simply is
what is the price tag for your stress
right now and who is paying that price
tag because often we are paying the
price tag and I love that Michaelson
does already we don't have to be stuck
and so if you're sitting around then
you're wondering my suggestion is it's
already have a price tag and to
Michael's Point earlier let's not wait
until he becomes a crisis which is
usually most of us though myself
included and and that we pay much bigger
price tag
Mike I'd love to hear your thoughts too
on this if and I I agree completely this
is both a wonderful question and Wanda a
wonderful answer so in full agreement
yes I I agree often the point where we
think our difficulty to move Beyond
normal stress and reached a serious
point is that point where indeed the
patterns have played out to an area
where we can no longer ignore them where
we become clearly undeniably harmful to
ourselves or those around us and as you
said I wanted the key is we TR want to
try as much as possible but try as much
as possible to not get there because
even what we accept as normal life most
of that is going to be based upon these
patterns that we are dangerously falling
into and if we're falling into them on a
daily basis then I think we are in
general um that's where on a daily basis
we need to start working out of them and
so going back to lawana's point we don't
want to wait until until something
horrible happens the key is we want to
start these daily practices right away
and begin working on our patterns with
hopefully a realization that if we do so
we may not as often reach those crisis
points and also as we go I think we'll
realize what we often consider to be
normal stress
isn't so normal it's just because we've
rationalized this as being
the normal unhappiness that we live with
and maybe we shouldn't be telling
ourselves we should be living with that
normal level of unhappiness so full
agreement on I think that's a beautiful
answer
yeah I I really appreciate this we have
a few more questions coming in which I'm
so glad that they were asked because
this is actually something that I've
been thinking too so you mentioned that
in a moment of Crisis
um that this is really apparent right
like if we're holding hot coffee and it
spills it's clearly hot but sometimes
when we're holding the cup right we
don't actually realize what inside of it
is hot or is keeping our hands full and
actually creating a lot of energy and
drain from us
so we have kind of two questions from
the audience and I'm hoping that we can
kind of put them together someone writes
is it possible that we avoid frequently
for such a long period of time that we
are no longer even sure that we're
avoiding it has become our way of being
and similarly related someone asks how
do you separate a pattern and who you
are where's the difference and so how do
you identify this before the moment of
Crisis and you have coffee hot coffee
spilled all over and you realize it's
hot
either of you whoever wants to start go
ahead and jump in
Wonderland on the avoidance one
um I love that question about avoidance
because once the pattern is formed our
brain the way our brain is wired it
should maintain the pattern and and the
reason being is it takes a lot less
energy to believe a distorted pattern
than to actually update your software
right because when Michael and I have
been talking about this idea that we can
change and then we have to start daily
practice but it takes effort to do that
and so once you developed and avoidance
practice you tend to keep avoid let me
give you an example
for longest times I thought I was just
very good at responding to emails fast
the emails would come and I just respond
about five years ago I realized that
what I was doing was avoiding my
emotions and email to come upset me
instead of being able to tolerate my
discomfort I just would do me a really
bad fast and then I would do what
Michael said I rationalize well I'm just
very fast and I'm very good but I was
actually playing a price tag that's why
avoidance is the problem right because
eventually somebody called me in their
office and they're like Luana you know
you don't have to respond at midnight to
an email that it's you're clearly upset
about right because what happens when
I'm responding I'm just avoiding
emotions and because I'm anxious I'm not
on my thinking brain I'm on my emotional
brain which means I'm not very being
logical correct and so the first piece
is if you are asking the question am I
avoiding ask yourself one thing if I
chose to go against that anxiety okay
it's what I call opposite action so
you're anxious and for me imagine that I
want to answer that email
if I don't answer how would I feel and
you should feel slightly more anxious
because if you choose to go opposite to
the anxiety you're gonna have discomfort
but that kind of discomfort is the
discomfort we're talking about sitting
with your emotions so that you can
actually bring their temperature down
and so that's how I personally separate
I ask myself you know on my dating days
um so long gone but I remember hating
dating and I remember like my brain
saying don't go on that date and if I
were to ask myself if I go am I going to
feel more or less uncomfortable and at
first I'd feel more uncomfortable but
why would I do that because I wanted to
have a family I wanted to have a partner
and so I then chose opposite action from
the avoidance to live a better life
and I think I took one of your questions
I don't know if I took both in I think I
got too excited about everyone so I'm
going to give it to Michael maybe he can
take the second question I'll be more
than happy to so wonderful answer and
yeah I will then focus a little bit more
in the second although it's directly
related to the first as well so let me
say a few words about one of the ideas
that arises in early China that I find
really telling about this so first to
contrast so certainly in America but
this has now gone Global we'll often use
terminology like the following we'll say
oh I should spend my life looking within
finding myself finding my true self and
part of that is with the idea that we
mentioned before learning to love and
embrace myself for who I really am now
this sounds great it sounds like the way
we can liberate ourselves and going back
to the second part of the second
question the focus would be what you're
finding there clearly is your true self
as opposed to these patterns that we're
falling into so let let me give a
contrasting way of putting it from early
China a very standard idea that will
arise in early China is we are messes we
are a mess of stuff when we are born
we're a mess of emotions
desires faculties energies and we're all
equally messes and then when we become
over time depends on what we do in life
um patterns we fall into practices we
fall into conventions we are born into
which means going back to the heart of
the second question much of what we
often think is being our true self you
know the real me
think of is very likely a bunch of
patterns that you've owned into now that
of course gets to the heart of that
second question which is okay well if
that's true is there no self there and
the answer is there definitely is but
the self is what you make of it which
means think of your life as you creating
and constructing an extraordinary self
the way you would construct a work of
art but not in a final moment when the
art is done but it's a lifelong process
where you are becoming something
extraordinary something beyond what you
could currently imagine which means
again going back to that second question
what you're doing on a daily basis is
not finding that true self that's
perfectly acceptable if you're you know
miserable but it's you you're assuming
most of the patterns you're falling into
can be worked on and tweaked and changed
and altered and what you will become out
of that process
that's the self it's the self is what
you create through this work and it
means getting back to the heart of the
one is arguments here
um what you're doing is breaking out of
your patterns and learning to really
work with the world build extraordinary
relationships in ways that your patterns
will never allow you to do and as long
as we keep thinking those patterns are
just who we are we will never be able to
break out of
I love that picture of like your life is
this painting that's evolving over time
and and it's like and every day when you
paint a little corner of it it sheds a
little more light
um I just such a great imagery thank you
it is a great image it reminds me of
when I was a kid you know and you only
have like the small 12-pack of crayons
and then over time you get more and
that's like a really exciting experience
um I really also appreciate about your
response Michael that you started to
kind of talk about kind of the hopeful
side of this
um the like opportunity to change for
the better and it really aligns with one
of the questions that we just received
from the audience that's talking about
mental peace and so kind of that more
positive light so the question is is
mental peace based on respecting others
patterns or should we push past them to
scramble that pattern and in parentheses
just thinking about family members or
Partners or friends Michael what are
your initial thoughts of this question
yes what a wonderful question and the
way I'd like to address it is let me
give a couple of analogies um which
might sound like a very weird answer but
bear with me for a few sentences so are
we capable of doing the kinds of work
that Luana and I are talking about and
the answer is absolutely just think of
Arenas in our lives where we do things
like this
um if you've ever learned a musical
instrument it's a lot of work I mean we
spend years and years and years training
yourself but if you succeed after those
years by really doing it you can become
an extraordinary musician either
professional or even just an amateur who
can feel the music feel the fellow
players feel the audience we're capable
of it um Sports same thing I mean none
of us are born able to bounce a
basketball or kick a soccer ball we
spend years doing this and we can train
ourselves to become extraordinary
um if we are capable of doing this then
the question would be why in the world
don't we do this for our daily life we
know we are capable of training
ourselves to sense the world better
relate to people better connect with
people better we just don't do it now
again that might sound like a bizarre
answered the question but now let me
return to the heart of it
um what this would mean is if you're in
a family do you simply scramble your
patterns and try to become a radically
new person no that would be kind of deep
like sitting down at a piano before
you've done your lessons and playing
randomly um it would not be fun for you
and very painful for the word people who
had to listen what it would mean on the
contrary is you're learning to really
relate to your family members you're
learning to sense them in their
complexity you're learning not to Simply
respond to them by wrote pattern which
is sadly the way we often do you're
trying training yourself to really learn
to listen to them and therefore grow
through those relationships you're doing
the same thing with your friends with
the larger world and it's literally the
same sort of work we do if we're
learning a sport or learning a musical
instrument it's about learning to in
this case listen to them sense them grow
from them work with them grow through
those relationships and
what will happen with your family if you
do this
um it won't be really scrambling up the
patterns it will be you'll really relate
to them and you will really build
extraordinary relationships which mean
you and they will grow in ways you could
not now even imagine and it's daily work
it's a lot of work but like when you're
learning a musical instrument it's at
first it seems like a lot of work but
then it comes it becomes incredibly
exciting and I would say it's all the
more so with relationships as the
relationships become deeper and you're
more connected it just it's like this
the snowball effects where it just
Builds on itself and you just you want
to keep building that relationship and
going back to the the metaphor of the
work of art
um again you're forming a work of art in
a way that goes beyond what you could
have imagined it would be but it's the
process that is so extraordinary
yeah thank you for answering that we've
had actually a lot of questions come in
about really how to support others Dr
Luana I wonder if you could add a little
bit more to this kind of you know if
we're playing if we're learning to play
soccer you know what is the the first
step of what we should do to really
support others who are struggling with
anxiety or just feeling unhappy in their
everyday life
sure so I love what you said Michael
because really imagine a worlds for a
second that people would spend as much
time training their brain as they do
their physical body right we have
pipelines for how much exercise we
should get and for a good health we have
to you know exercise this many days a
week for this numbers but nobody talks
about training our brain and so this
idea I think that's what I heard you say
Michael like you need to train your
brain and it is a lot of work let's not
lie about it it's a lot of work but
anything meaningful it's a lot of work
you don't get a degree about a lot of
work you don't learn how to play the
piano without a lot of work and so to to
just go to your question Anna you know
supporting others the first thing we
need to do is first make sure that we
are supporting ourselves because often I
hear that question about family members
and others in your support them but you
yourself are not living your best life
yourself is not training your brain and
so what happens is what Michael has been
talking about you just spin with each
other instead of actually being able to
do something so this this is my secret
power when things are spinning pause I
mean it just Shaws because if your
family member is spinning and often what
we do is we try to just go fix it people
need to be able to have their own
emotions people need to be able to learn
to manage their own emotions so one is
just pause and observe what's happening
check your own narrative in your brain
what are you saying to yourself about
what's happening and the other one is
this if you want to really support a
family member ask them what they need in
terms of help we're very creative about
what we think people need and we often
don't ask what they need and sometimes
it's like I said to my husband yesterday
he's like what do you want for Mother's
Day I'm like a nap in the sun in the
hammock that's awesome you could have
done a million things for me it was the
only thing I wanted and because he asked
he was able to go play soccer with our
son and I was able to take my nap and it
was just perfect and so pause and ask
among two um recommendations for family
members
don't even want to do you have any
tricks for how to pause I can imagine
that would be so hard if you really want
to do something or really want to help
someone how do we actually pause
avoidance wants you to do something
always
um it's always awarding you around so
here's a trick um when we are anxious or
stressed so we are in our limbic system
we're on fight flight or freeze we're in
the anxious brain right which is going
to commend you to try to do something
what we know from cognitive behavior
therapies even the act of writing so
imagine that you're really anxious
putting down your thoughts linking
thoughts to emotions and to behavior
just by writing simply you're actually
activating your prefrontal cortex the
part of your brain that allows you to
slow down to execute to plan and so
sometimes I am so anxious and I can't
even think of why I'm anxious I make my
brain spinning I literally take my
journey when I just write down the
thoughts until I get to like oh this is
the thought usually for me is I'm not
enough and then I go oh that's that old
belief I don't have to do this anymore
so just writing it's like an awesome
trick the other one is gonna sound so
odd to many people but I'm going to tell
you a secret from the electrical
behavior therapy that's super effective
especially if you have a toddler home
like I do who at times is melting down
in in dialectical behavior therapy when
you really really really stress on one
technique they use is to hold two ice
cubes it's called distress tolerance so
you just hold an ice cube in your hand
until it burns a little bit that
physical pain slows down the emotional
brain and you have a little window
before you act there so that's a little
secret
that's amazing I'm going to ask one more
quick follow-up question you've
mentioned this term emotional brain and
thinking brain a lot can you tell us a
little bit more about like the science
behind those two terms and what you mean
when you say that
so the way I think about the brain and
it's much more complicated in this but I
try to think of things very
simplistically there's two parts of our
brain that are always competing for
energy and Attention our thinking brain
to perform the fourth acts which helps
us to do a math problem execute plan and
then the old lizard brain which is the
amygla the limbic system which really is
the fight flight or freeze part of the
brain and you know if you if you put me
in an MRI machine and gave me a bunch of
math problems and I was solving really
well and then you showed me a picture of
like a big lion out of cell in my
reaction time will go down and so the
way I think about is when Once is on the
other one tends to be a lot off work
like offline a little bit and so you
always want to sort of be playing with
your brain to be able to do what Mike
was talking about like we need to be
training our brain that's why I like
talking about brain health instead of
mental health because the brain's just
on the organ and it can be actually
trained to work for us does that help
Anna
that does thank you for those tips I'm
curious going back um to this kind of
brain training and pivoting a little bit
to Michael's kind of analogy too of like
painting this picture how do we actually
start to change these patterns Michael
like how would you how do we Foster this
masterpiece of self then
in your work
absolutely I would and this is in full
agreement with luana's way of putting
this which is beautiful
um I would say you begin with the
seemingly most ludicrously mundane
aspects of your daily life because
that's where these patterns set in and
that's where we need to change them so
when I say ludicrously mundane I mean
literally down to when you were walking
down a street notice how little of what
is around you you're actually even
seeing when you're interacting with
people notice how little of
real interaction is actually occurring
including with very close friends and
family members note the degree to which
your just daily interactions are just
again these row patterns note the degree
to which your emotions are these Road
patterns um as we sadly know family
patterns can set in and can continue for
decades and even move on to the next
Generations because it's showing the
degree to which we do this now that's
the negative part so immediately jumping
to the the good part getting back to the
heart of your question Anna so how do we
break this you go back to that mundane
level when you're walking down a street
on a daily basis start training yourself
to really see what's going on around you
and this is training you will not
normally be doing this um if you try to
think back what is your office space
like where you work every day you
probably can say very little about it
what is the street light that you walk
to the bus every day on you probably
don't know even though you walk on it
every day you start training yourself to
start seeing things when you're
interacting with people you start
training yourself to start really
relating to them as opposed to relating
by row pattern you begin to see yo this
person is who's just mean and that
person is nice you begin to realize no
you're in a pattern where in the latter
case
it's nice that's good but this person is
mean you're probably doing something
that's pulling out that negative energy
from them so you're training yourself to
begin to really relate to them you're
beginning to sense what am I doing
that's drawing out that person's anger
or resentment how do I shift this
um with this family member who I just
keep having this daily fight with
can I shift that a little bit by simply
playing with different emotions taking
on different roles with that person
shifting how I interact with them
oftentimes at the most ludicrously basic
level at the beginning just using
different tones of Voice using different
body language
um these seemingly mundane things once
you begin working with them you begin
realizing you can really shift the
degree to which you're relating to the
world around you to people around you
and once you begin to sense that shift
then you can begin doing it at an even
higher level you can begin really
working on your relationships really
getting a sense of you know why with my
co-worker just involved in this constant
jealousy resentment competitive I'm
battle and it's amazing how these
seemingly unchangeable relationships can
be altered dramatically within literally
a few weeks it's incredible and families
maybe takes a few months but still it is
absolutely doable but again you begin
with the most mundane aspects of your
daily life and then you begin working
from there
I love this
afternoon
the reason I love this Michael is many
many years whenever I started to work
with a new client they want to you know
everybody wants to advance fast we all
do that's the Human Condition and I'd
say to them how often do you even notice
your shower in the morning because most
of us are having an argument with
somebody later in the day on that shower
or like brushing your teeth how many
people actually pay attention to
brushing their teeth most of the time
you're already on the to-do list six
things ahead trying to get something
else done and so I actually think
there's Magic on the mundane because
those are the moments that we wake up to
like oh my God my life is alchematic
Pilots so much and and if we can't even
notice those moments then it's really
hard to change the more complex things
so I love your answer
yeah I really appreciate both your
answers to play just a little bit of
Devil's Advocate and the thought that I
had coming to mind my own chatter
pattern here
um is
are we missing anything by being in the
present and I mean that um and by
starting to notice some of these
patterns more like the conversation you
mentioned Luana about in the future
right talking with trying to plan
something right if we're
always noticing what is around us do we
lose anything by not being able to plan
or help help me break that down further
I mean I don't think we're losing
anything I think we're thriving
um because we are not I don't think
either Mike and I are saying one of the
costs that of course we have to have
moments of planning right but let me
just argue that the shower perhaps is a
great place to think but also sometimes
we're just replaying things we're not
actually planning right we're really in
that anxious brain just ruminating or
thinking about thinking or just worrying
about something versus what would look
different would be like okay I have a
presentation later today and I'm just
running through my presentation that's
planning that's practicing but that's
not the I the argument I think we're
both making is this idea that like
automatic pilot robs you the ability to
just be present and actually it takes a
lot more energy to worry than to be
present once you're present like your
sleep is better you know you engage in a
way that's much more meaningful and so I
don't I don't think he rubs Us Michael
what do you think I fully agree I so
often when we think of plans we think of
them in the sense that well it's the way
to get head and why is that if I decide
well in advance I want to do X Y and Z
so well in advance can mean you know
what I want to become 20 years from now
but it can also mean like what I'll do
in that meeting that I have later today
either way we're focused on that plan
and then everything is aimed at trying
to get us to that point the danger is
exactly as you said Moana that means we
are literally not seeing anything going
on around us because we're so focused on
being that X at the meeting or that X in
20 years and everything is aimed at that
which means precisely because we're not
seeing what's going on around us we
literally cease to interact with those
around us we cease to see what is around
us and it means we cease to be open to
possibilities so going to the extreme
example that 20 years I will be X
well if you're really open to the world
around you there are probably I'll take
out probably there are possibilities
that will be opening up to you
constantly that you will literally never
ever see and precisely by being open to
them that is what will allow you to
really grow now are you planning yes but
in a very different way than we usually
use that term then you are really
growing as a human being in this
incredibly creative mode that we've been
mentioning and that is how you can
really be something extraordinary in 20
years or even at that meeting later in
the day because you're living your life
and you'll be more fully present so I
agree completely it sounds like a
paradox to say by being more present you
can be warfully open to the future but I
think it is absolutely the case
that's radical and so helpful we have a
few more questions coming in I want to
try to get to some of them before our
time is up
um and I think one of these links a
little bit to what we've been talking
about in terms of potentially being
present and also kind of when our brain
starts to run about different things the
question is what can we do to care less
about other people's negative opinions
I'm saying smiles from both of you who
wants to jump in Luanda please uh sure I
mean
we
there's two types of be very sort of
black and white but there's two ways we
can choose to live our lives one is an
emotion Driven Life and the other one is
a value-driven life and whenever we care
a lot about what other people think
we're very likely in a narrative about
ourselves that's being run by our own
emotions right
um and so it's really this idea of
Shifting your perspective so in in my
book bold move which is coming out next
week I talk very openly about the shifts
I have to make and what do I mean by
shifting is really learning to talk to
yourself as if you're talking to your
best friend right it's becoming a bit of
a detective it's questioning the
narrative in our brains and so if we're
really really caring it means we're
saying something about ourselves very
likely something like I'm not enough I'm
not good enough I'm unlovable and that
narrative is really what's feeding your
insecurities about what other people
think of you and that's why I said a few
minutes earlier it's really important to
work on the self before you work on the
context around you because both need
work but if you're walking around with
lenses they're distorted I I think of
them as like glasses right it's like we
have magnifying glasses on but wore them
for so long that we are not even aware
of what we're saying to ourselves and so
it's time to take the glasses off
literally and really examine what the
narrative in your brain is shift talk to
yourself as if your best friend and last
thing I was saying
thoughts are not facts let me say that
again thoughts are not facts I know we
want them to be facts but they're not
they're just something that we're coming
up in our brain and if it's arbitrary
anyhow why do we have to be so mean to
ourselves
such a good question
um I I really appreciate that response I
think it's really really helpful and I
appreciate both of your tips that you're
kind of giving throughout this I think
there's so much richness and I hope
everyone is taking notes
um as much as I am too while doing this
so
um we've had a few questions come up
um and I'd love to hear from both of you
about your views on meditation
specifically the questions are around do
you feel it can help reduce anxiety if
practiced regularly do you think that we
can improve mental health and well-being
by meditation and just your general
views on it Michael we'll start with you
sure I'll answer with an emphatic yes
absolutely
um but let me also mention a danger of
the ways that we will often do it so a
danger of the ways we often do
meditation is simply to say okay to deal
with all of my stress and unhappiness
and anger and resentment you know blah
blah blah blah or normal lives on the
way we deal with that is stopping for a
few moments breathing deeply calming
down and then that will give me the
strengths return to my life unchanged
and needless to say that's not the goal
the goal is not to calm yourself down so
you can live your life your miserable
life um and changed
um the goal is to change how you're
living your life and so meditation works
if you do the work of what that really
means which is it has to affect what
happens when you walk out of that
meditation room or off of that Matt will
you do your meditation or in the core
wonder where you're breathing deeply it
is not helping if it doesn't really
affect how you live your life and that's
the key so meditation can help but only
if then when you are deeply dealing with
your daily life you're really using that
momentary calm you felt to really alter
your patterns really work with the world
if you're simply calming yourself down
to continue with life unchanged then it
can be downright to interest
um you're just giving yourself a a good
drug to be able to make it through your
life without changing anything so the
key is you must do going back to
lawanda's key Point here you must do
that work on a daily basis to really
alter your life and meditation is
helpful if it's part of that program of
allowing you to do so
I love this I can't tell you how many
people I've worked with that avoid
through meditation they're like if I
just meditate then it's gonna be fine
you're just avoiding discomfort and
there's no life without discomfort and
so you know there's so much science
showing the meditation can change our
brain but the work is on and off that
cushion and the off is perhaps even more
important than the on the cushion I love
your point Michael that's so true
really helpful
um thank you so much I have one more
question that I'd like to pose to both
of you that I think is an excellent
question that we got from the audience
to wrap us up today you both have
different courses talking about
happiness and living a good life talking
about manage anxiety and living a bold
life and so the final question for today
is can we be happy and live with anxiety
at the same time
Michael I'll start with you a wonderful
question
um and the answer is absolutely and let
me even introduce another term here
coming from the Chinese tradition which
is joy and what they mean by Joy is
often when we think of Happiness um you
can have a deep happiness that's that's
that is joyous in the way that that they
will Define it but often when we think
of things like happiness and anxiety and
anger and and and
resentment all of our usual emotional
responses to the world
um the sense is we try to think okay I
want more of the moments when I feel
happy and fewer of the moments when I'm
feeling anxious and the view that will
come in from this notion of joy is what
you're trying to get is this deep
feeling of Joy it's this deep connection
um Joy here that the Chinese term is the
same as music I think it's like
resonating musically with those around
you with the world around you that's
what you're trying to get now getting
back to the heart of the question that
doesn't mean horrible things won't
happen to you of course it's life
horrible things will happen to you
you'll be sad you'll be anxious that
will happen but what you're training
yourself to reach is a point where that
anxiety isn't debilitating and again
going back to the heart of what we've
been mentioning that anxiety isn't a
product of your patterns in life it's
simply a momentary thing you feel you
sense the pattern playing out you work
against it something horrible happens of
course it's sad but then you you work
around that because you have this depth
of joy that you've been training
yourself for years to slowly develop and
therefore getting back to the heart of
the question the answer is emphatically
yes but not again in the happiness in
the sense that we often use it like
something good happened I I'm happy
there's I found an ice cream cone of
them in my fridge and that tastes good I
feel momentarily happy sure that can
exist with anxiety but your just
emotions are going back and forth what
you're seeking is this joyousness that
allows you to sense that great happiness
work with the anxiety and work with all
the other emotions because it comes out
of this depth of joy
so agree
um you know my grandmother used to
describe this as you know when people
are changing they tend to be like a rock
they want to like stay where they are
and you know to Michael's point it's
like this black and white I mean they're
happy or sad right and my grandmothers
should say that to have a happy life you
have to be more like the water that you
go around the rock you go on top you go
on the bottom you're flexible and and in
my brain that's cognitive flexibility is
the ability of handling the challenging
moments of life with more Grace with
more skills actually and knowing that
they're going to be ups and downs but if
we practice these skills that Mike and I
have been talking about you're much
better prepared to handle the lows and
you can really be present in those
moments of joy and I love the idea of
Joy even more because it's those little
micro moments right when you look at
somebody you have been working all day
and like I try to practice this in the
end of my day when I go see my kid I
like I try to really look at him right
can I have a little moment of just being
present because often we just going on
to the next thing and so I think we can
live incredible lives with anxiety as
long as we are moving towards the things
that matter the most as long as we're
value driven and we're present
um and honestly you're making anxiety
work for you
at least I do
thank you so much
um thank you Luana and thank you Michael
for sharing your time your wisdom for
being present for helping us all break
out of patterns during this and think in
new ways and this is just a small part
of how we're changing and so we are so
grateful thank you so much for everyone
that tuned in today thank you for all of
your questions I wish we could have
gotten to them all but I encourage you
to continue to Grapple with this topic
and mull it over bye
participating in the course Michael's
course is currently live the path to
happiness and so go ahead and start that
today the Bold move is released Dr
luana's book is released next Tuesday
and her course Launches on June 28th and
so again I just encourage you to enroll
in both of those you will get a discount
code for being part of this presentation
in the next day or so to your email and
so we look forward to seeing you in both
of those courses thank you all so much
thank you Anna Michael so great to be
here with you thank you Luanda it's been
wonderful to be here with you and Anna
thank you so much for your wonderful
work
of course I'll hand it back over to the
Harvard online team thank you to
everyone who made this run today
great
thank you so much thank you Anna thank
you Dr lawana thank you Michael and also
thank you to all of you who have joined
us from around the world today
we hope you'll join us inside these
wonderful courses building personal
resilience and the path to happiness if
you've registered for and attended this
presentation you'll receive a discount
code in your inbox in the next day or so
and you can also find a discount code
and Link in the chat
just as a reminder the content provided
in this webinar is intended for
informational purposes only and should
not be considered as medical advice the
content is not and should not be relied
upon as medical advice and should not be
used to make a clinical diagnosis to
provide treatment or to replace or
overrule a licensed Health Care
provider's judgment
thanks again goodbye everyone and see
you again soon